[موسيقى]
حفل تاريخي فريد لم تشهدوا بريطانيا منذ
سبعه عقود
عرض فخم لمهرجان يعود تاريخه الى الف عام
لكن تم تكييفه ليعكس بريطانيا القرن
الحادي والعشرين
يوم طويل شد انظار العالم بدا بخروج موكب
الملك تشارلز ثالث من قصر باكينغهام جالسا
في عربه اليوبيل الماسي الملكيه متوجها
الى كنيسه وست منستر
بعد وصول الموكب الى الكنيسه ترجلت تشارلز
من العربه خلفه زعماء دينيون ورؤساء وزراء
من بينهم رئيس وزراء بريطانيا ريشيسوناك
[موسيقى]
الاحتفال بدا في تمام الحاديه عشره صباحا
بتوقيت لندن
تخللته مقطوعات موسيقيه اختارها الملك
بنفسه منها 12 مقطوعه كتبت خصيصا لهذه
المناسبه
المرحله الاولى من التتويج تعرف بالاقرار
حيث تم تقديم الملك تشارلز الى الرعيه
يرافقه اعلان كبير اساقفه
هو الملك
[موسيقى]
اما المرحله الاخيره فكانت اللحظه
المنتظره جلوس الملك على العرش شامخا
واثقا
[موسيقى]
طريق العوده الى قصر باكينغهام كانت
بالعربه الملكيه الذهبيه التي يبلغ عمرها
260 عاما لتختتم احتفالات التتويج الرسميه
بالقاء التحيه الملكيه من الملك والملكه
من على شرفه القصر الغربيه
اياد حمود العربيه
مدهش رائع تماما احببت كل دقيقه رغم اننا
كنا مبللين انه لشرف وامتياز ان نكون هنا
كانت تستحق البقاء طوال الليل في الجو
القارس
الحصول على مكان جيد والتقاط افضل الصور
ان تراه حقيقيا امامك وهو داخل العربه
ضعفا انه احتفال رائع للبلاد ان نكون خلف
ملكنا ونراه بشكل مباشر وهي فرصه واحده في
حياتنا حضرنا هنا ليله امس وشاهدنا
المراسم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات